[Musique]
voilà donc sur le frontispice il ya donc
aux hommes la patrie reconnaissante
et vous mesdames vous avez demandé au
président qu'il fasse un geste de façon
à ce que soient honorées des femmes qui
par leurs actions leurs talents aux
leurs découvertes ont servi la
démocratie le progrès ou les arts et les
carrières d'encausse
cette initiative pourquoi vous trois
pourquoi nous 3 je pense parce que cela
nous choque est également le gie machine
et pourquoi cette initiative il me
semble que le moment est venu d'abord
parce que le panthéon et est
spécialement panthéon le pantalon c'est
le lieu de la tradition c'est le lieu où
tout ce qui a fait l'histoire et la
grandeur de la france et rassembler et
penser que les femmes n'y ont plus
aucune part me semble tout à fait
étrange
et particulièrement en ce moment où tout
même les mentalités françaises en
changer ou les les femmes tiennent dans
la vie professionnelle dans le
développement de ce pays
une place qui est pour incontestablement
égales aux hommes et qu'on accepte
désormais même si parfois on vous la
conteste
ça fait partie de ce qui est acquis et
par conséquent il est temps de les
remettre dans l'histoire six nouvelles
dans votre action politique vous êtes
beaucoup heurté au machisme quotidien
donc oui beaucoup beaucoup mais surtout
eu jeu d'ailleurs je voudrais remercier
françoise gaspard parce que c'est elle
qui a eu cette idée et je pense que
c'est une idée importante parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous vivons dans un monde
de symboles que qu'il n'y ait aucune
femme au panthéon c'est nier ce que dans
le passé les femmes ont apporté à la
patrie mais c'est aussi presque nier ce
que la femme apporte aujourd'hui à notre
pays et ce que l'on peut espérer
qu'elles apporteront dans l'avenir c'est
en fait considéré que le monde ait fait
d'hommes qu'il ya des femmes qui sont à
la maison qui s'occupe des enfants qui
les font d'ailleurs ses enfants aussi
mais on n'a pas encore reconnu qu'elle
avait calé complètement partie prenante
de notre de tout ce qui se fait dans le
monde 2 to sky de tout ce qu'est la
france de la rôle de jeanne d'arc a eu
on peut citer les de très nombreuses
parce qu'elles sont liées alors je crois
que si le président la république allait
danseuse dans le
le sens que nous souhaitons et qu'il y
est une femme elle serait le symbole de
la reconnaissance de la réalité des
femmes de leur rôle de leur existence et
que ça irait beaucoup plus loin que une
ou deux femmes du passé qui pourraient y
être admise il est propre sinon par
françoise gaspard comment explique-t-on
personnalités comme par exemple marie
curie ne soit pas posé la question aux
hommes politiques aux présidents de
républiques qui ont décidé du transfert
des femmes au panthéon
je crois qu'il m'a vu il a bien dit il
n'y a pas de ya pas de démocratie sans
mémoire et la mémoire de la france ça
doit être aussi les femmes les femmes
ont concouru à la fois la grandeur de la
france à sa liberté
on parle de marie curie mais il ya aussi
de grandes résistantes qui convertit
femmes qui ont laissé leur vie dans le
combat pour la liberté de la france
croit qu'il serait heureux que le
président de république prenne une
initiative de ce type
personnellement je serais attaché à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas une seule femme qui
soit la vie va envoyer au panthéon qui
serait une sorte d' albi mais qu'il y en
ait au moins deux ou trois le jour cette
initiative alors précisément à faire un
petit tour de table si le si le
président reprend mot est dit donnez moi
des idées fait moins des suggestions
donnant lesquels non je dirais en
premier lieu marie curie certainement je
ne sais pas comment on pourrait et
simone veil l'évoqué jeanne d'arc je ne
sais pas comment on pourrait retrouver
ce qui est des restes calcinés jeanne
d'arc symboliquement il faudrait faire
quelque chose je pense parce qu'elle a
un carnet françoise gaspard évoque à la
résistance
quelle que soit l'idée que l'on et
d'histoire elle incarnait la résistance
et oui et moi j'ajouterais la la récente
résistante en résistance des âniers du
aurait dont on se souvient je n'ai pas
de nom ici à donner d'abord parce qu'un
certain nombre très résistante quand
elles ont disparu certaine je ne sais
même pas si leurs dépouilles église je
pense à quelqu'un comme berty albrecht
par exemple qui a été décapité en
allemagne et je ne sais pas si on a
retrouvé son corps s'il a été rapatriée
si ce serait possible on va je dirais
que c'est le symbole qui est aujourd'hui
me paraît vraiment
très important et justement par exemple
quand on parle de la résistance
les femmes n'ont joué un très grand rôle
et que quelquefois quelquefois on
l'oubli parce qu'elles sont rentrées
chez elles et que on parle peu d'elles
elles sont âgées aujourd'hui
naturellement et que l on a oublié je
crois que les jeunes on a oublié le rôle
qu'elles ont joué et je ça a été vrai ça
a été vrai de tout le temps sous la
révolution française aussi les femmes
ont joué un rôle important et que moi je
crois que pour les femmes aujourd'hui
pour les jeunes femmes qui d'ailleurs
que je trouve formidable je veux dire qu
il ya une génération jeune femme que je
trouve absolument épatante et là je
trouve que ça serait pour elle un c pour
qu'elles seraient l'exploit d'aller aux
portes et on s'est dit au problème mais
ce gars qu on reconnaît notre rôle dans
ce dans d'autres pays et ce que nous
faisons
[Musique]